with parents like Tim McGraw and Faith
Hill it's no surprise that miss Gracie
McGraw has some serious musical talent
have you been giving her advice on
breaking into the music industry does
she listen to dad
no she doesn't listen to that she's way
more talented than I am anyway so she
don't need any advice for me she's a
hurt she's so bubbly and so she feels a
room up when she walks in and she sucked
got so much talent such a great
songwriter we're gonna hear from her
down the road for sure Tim couldn't help
but gush about his firstborn daughter at
the ACM Awards in Las Vegas where he
also performed his new single oht it's
just about you know looking at yourself
and what you can do to improve the world
when you can do be a good person what
you can do to sort of influence the
environment of people around you I
thought you were in an Instagram with
our Nancy O'Dell yesterday winter life
face I was are you here at 50 I am she's
backstage hiding yeah I was I was right
right by two tall blondes I'm happy that
way how beautiful does she look tonight
yeah she looks great she's I mean I'm
always way over my head for sure